hello everybody thank you for 10 minutes
good thank you for coming to my talk I
was I was very pleased West McKenney
decided not to show up today because I
was in competition for him for an
audience so thank you thank you for
coming I want to thank the organizers of
Pi data to start I've been to two or
three of these spiders they're my
favorite conferences of the year because
not only do we get to hear about
interesting topics we get great open
source github code from industry
professionals who have very similar
problems to those of working on so I
hope to be able to provide either one of
the two may be an interesting topic or a
few a few code that you can use in your
in your daily work today I'm going to be
talking about a correlation matrix
filtering algorithm that I I really like
it's due to who showed and Potter's but
they have used a variety of other
results in order to build this filter
just for a bit of motivation so so
correlation and covariance matrices are
widely used as input parameters and a
variety of financial models um asset
allocation probably being the most most
prominent covariance matrices are
usually inputs into those and they
unfortunately sometimes will suffer
estimation errors due to estimation
error that can sometimes come from
outliers in the data
I'm also noise and here at the data and
there's a variety of other issues that
can result in these these estimation
errors and if you have a poorly
estimated covariance a correlation
matrix that can influence subsequent
results and whenever the output of the
financial model are using yeah go up one
more than okay
and so I'm gonna examine one one
technique for removing some of this this
noise error that'll allow you and I'll
explain how it helps with asset
allocation models in particular and
making them more stable make the
optimization problems they have to deal
with more stable unknot asset allocation
and I'm gonna be dealing with sp500
daily data and also gonna credit
demo a new package called CB X PI that I
really like it's a very simple interface
to I think six different convex open
source convex optimizers and you'll see
from the code that's really easy to set
up your your problem in CB x pi and and
solve it so here's here's the rough
outline so first we're going to this
download of Wrangell S&P 500 daily price
data from Google Finance and then next
I'm gonna have a quick simulation I'm
going to simulate heavy-tailed time
serious sampling from student T
distributions I'm gonna estimate the
correlation matrix between these these
sample heavy-tailed time series these
simulated time series and we're gonna
look at the eigenvalues the distribution
will find it has a very nice structure
to it the distribution of eigenvalues of
the of the correlation matrix has a nice
nice structure to it and then we're
going to review a theorem of marchenko
and pass your which describes this
distribution and then we're going to use
this theorem as a basis to design a
noise filter on correlation matrices and
then we're going to apply this noise
filter to this sp500 data and then
that's going to result in two
correlation matrices one raw matrix that
we just estimate directly from the data
and a second filtered correlation matrix
and then from the correlation matrices
we're going to reconstruct the
covariance matrices and then use these
as inputs into a Markowitz type asset
allocation problem show that you don't
have significant difference so going
with the more stable chimera and slash
correlation matrix will lead to similar
results but you have more confidence
that you're not gonna run into numerical
issues and in the process
so the get started this is a first cell
is just what I used to download SP 500
data from Google Finance so this very
first Picard DF line is just the list of
S&P 500 stocks I think in a couple
months ago that there's a variety of
places you can get this online I just
put it in a CSV file and and read it in
and I fixed the start dates 1 1 2010 and
it's going to be going to the I think
yesterday is when I when I made it so
this main for loop uses it's basically
it's the loop around a very nice
function I think and pandas called the
data reader function so this data reader
function I you feed it a ticker and you
feed it a source Google being one source
Yahoo Finance being being another source
and you can feed it an optional start
date and end dates and that's basically
it what you'll get back is a table a
panda's data frame of end-of-day prices
for that stock from that source
you get adjusting clothes prices and get
volume information you get you get I
think five different fields I don't
remember at all it must be using the
adjusting dusted clothes prices I think
this isn't incredibly nice because I
remember about like eight years ago
before this was in place I spent a good
like two days using Bosch and see to go
and W get to go and we'll build all this
up myself but now it's all been done in
pandas so it's very easy to get in a day
in a banana and this main loop will
extract data for all S&P 500 stocks it
only takes about five minutes to gather
gather all the data and to store
everything and a single single data
friend catenate them all together and
then I just pickled that data frame so
later if I want to open it up I can just
do it do it directly instead of having
to rerun the the downloader so the next
portion is the is the simulation so
we're going to we're going to take the
simulation we're gonna take 2000 draws
2000 points per time series to represent
the returns from a student
from a student T distribution represent
the daily returns of 500 different time
series and we're gonna pick a student T
degree of freedom parameter 5 student T
distribution anytime the degree freedom
parameter is greater than 2 the
distribution has finite variance and
that will be key to something that comes
up in the in the future so this is 1 1 5
was a reasonable choice of parameter and
next thing to do is we're going to get
the cumulative returns of each of each
of these each of these time series in
order to construct the actual simulated
stock stock time series themselves and
they're gonna plot the distribution of
differences and one of the plots below
and we're also gonna plot going to
compute the correlation matrix these
time series and we're gonna look at its
eigen values and plot their distribution
so here it is first of all I'm in code
so the first line would have set that
degree of freedom parameter second line
we set the number of series time series
are gonna generate 500 third line the
number of points per time series and
then it takes just two lines of Python
to do to do all of this this is the
wonderful thing yes Heidi
yes these are all iid draws so this I
think this is one of the really nice
things about Python doing these types of
simulations it only takes a couple
couple lines to do it so in the in the
first line is the is the random sample
or and numpy there's this nice standard
T student T distribution sampler and you
can just specify the degree of freedom
and the type and the number of series of
points that you'd like to like to draw
and the next line so I've put everything
into a data frame compute the
correlation matrix take take an eigen
decomposition of it eigen values eigen
vectors and just take the eigen values
associated with it so two lines it's
done the rest of this plot plotting
plotting code so here are the here's the
code so this is a plot of the sample
paths 500 sample paths as well as the
mean path which is about zero which is
what you what you'd expect you see a few
outlier paths to the to the top at the
bottom that are a result of the fact
that we have student T samples they're
getting a lot of these heavy tail
drawers from them as post if we were
using gaussians for example they
wouldn't go that quite that far out
student T distribution czar a lot better
class of distributions to use to model
return densities and finance anything
you looked at if you look at rates you
look at commodities you look at stocks
you look at any type of returns I've
never seen a Gaussian in finance maybe
it exists I always see something with
that with heavy tails and it's usually
student tees or other heavy tail
distributions I find to be good model
it's one line per simulated time serious
and then the red lines is the average I
just plot the overlay the average onto
it so this next one I just took a I took
a cross-section in these time series at
the very last points and this is a very
nice plot I like and Seabourn check it
out it's I think it was this just a plot
was what's the name of it so there's a
histogram underneath it's a histogram
standard but I also I love this there's
one particular kernel density estimation
method called nonparametric kernel
density estimation that's in both sigh
pi and I'm pretty sure it's in
scikit-learn as well and this it's
missus they fit using that method over
the over the density itself and assuming
you have enough data I think this is one
of the my preferred ways to estimate
densities of returns because you have a
lot more degree of freedom over any
parametric method that you might use
you're not so you're not now restricting
yourself to parametric class you're
using a more generic set of methods go
NC estimation to divine divinity the one
drawback in this method is the way the
the bandwidth is chosen is a little ad
hoc cross-validation is better but it
takes longer but it's still it's still a
nice just one one line to to call it and
just to get a quick visualization of
this the last plots the what I think the
interesting plot so we took all these we
have these 500 time series we compute
their correlation matrix and now compute
the eigenvalues of that correlation
matrix and now plot a histogram of those
eigenvalues and this is what it looks
like there's structure to it it's not
just computer it's not that uniform
uniform random this structure to it one
thing to note there's a lower bound
another thing to note is there's an
upper bound and then it's slightly
skewed to the to the left of this in
this case and so it turns out that there
is a theorem about this there's a random
matrix theory theorem which I'm
paraphrasing here getting getting a
little bit out of the the true
mathematical setting of it for for more
coherence here's the way it can be
stated so if if X is a random in by our
variable so here n is gonna be the
number of points in the time series r is
going to be the number of time series
whose entries are all
iid I'm have finite constant variance
this is why we're using this the great
freedom v we're not getting too small we
have infinite variance and ID finite
constant variance and these are the only
assumptions we're gonna make in the
theorem we're not making any
distributional assumptions on the type
of distribution these are drawn through
only these very very relaxed assumptions
then the eigenvalues of the correlation
matrix corresponding to X are
distributed by this relatively simple
functional form F of lambda equals QQ is
a constant divided by 2 Pi Lambda L and
as the variable times the square root of
a quadratic lambda plus which is going
to be the upper limit of this eigenvalue
distribution that we saw minus lambda
times lambda minus lambda minus and land
is going to find in this interval and
the minus will have the plus and here
lambda plus and the minus these these
upper and lower eigenvalues are only a
function of q and this constant q is
only a function of n and r the number of
points in a time series and the number
of Time series themselves for any
distribution you like as long as you
have finite variance and so the first
time I I saw this I was I was rather
made about this is a great great theorem
I would never
expected this like beforehand that it
would be would be true and this was
developed by Marchenko and pasture in a
pure pure math setting and it serves as
the main result that that was an
application of the showed and Potter's
into the development this next noise
filter that we're going to going to talk
about so here just just a check I in
this next cell I implemented this this
this distribution and overlaid it on top
of the histogram that we previously saw
and you can see it it fits it fairly
fairly well out in the right tail we
didn't quite have enough large enough
matrix to get fill it up but if we get
larger would probably get another
another bin on the very end again that
look at the last minute okay now we're
going to apply this to sp500 data first
we're gonna do a little little dumb data
wrangling so gonna specify a start start
and end date for the data in date being
I think like two days two days ago ten
in one October first and first we have
we have to make sure all our time series
are are normalized one of the
requirements of the theorem is that they
all have the same variance so we're
gonna apply a normalization step to all
of our all-time series so here it is in
the code the first line is just an
implementation of this lambda plus which
is going to be used as a threshold and
filter we're going to design next next
part we just read in the data if it's
not already in our local variables read
it in from our pickle file and specify
both the start and end date and then I
want to just for simplicity purposes so
make a list of tickers and compute the
lengths of all the tickers sometimes the
names haven't been in the S&P 500 long
enough to where you have a significant
enough data in order to do computations
on they might have only been in there
for 30 days so for purpose of simplicity
I'm just going to compute the length of
all of the S&P 500 time series that
we're looking at and we're gonna take
the mode of all of those which will
correspond to the ones that have been in
the index the longest and the only
series that realize this this load
length I'm
to keep and so it'll get we rough with
like like four hundred and sixty times
dime Superseries roughly but not not
quite this way everything is uniform and
nice I don't have to worry about any
feeling any gaps or interpolation or
such and then the next little blocks of
normalization step so we just D mean
each one of these time series and we
divide by its variance so all of them
have variance one and compute the
returns for each for each series so now
we have normalized normalized returns
for each one of these four hundred and
sixty or seventy so serious with this
guess the returns everything
everything's with insurance and so
here's here's the part of that filtering
instructions so so we're interested in
this this theorem applies to correlation
matrices so the correlation matrix is
defined right here if x and y are two
time series with components X sub I and
y sub I the correlations the covariance
of x and y divided by the square root of
variance of x times the variance of Y
and you're just use the unbiased
definition for the covariance and
variance of a variable is the covariance
the variable with itself and they just
find the mean now therefore to be
complete so if you let Rho be the road
to note the the correlation matrix
I'm gonna call its eigen values lambda
sub I and the corresponding eigen
vectors for each lambda sub I isa by and
what are the eigenvalues lambda ones the
largest going down to lately and is
four-person notation so we can decompose
through and do an eigen eigen vector
decomposition of the correlation matrix
and Sigma Lambda Sigma inverse we're
here Sigma is this the collection of
eigen vectors for the matrix and lambdas
diagonal matrix that contains the eigen
values sort and sorted in order from
lambda 1 being the upper left component
all the way down to the lambda N and
there's some issues I was getting some
very slight imaginary parts when I was
doing this will be like some like 1 plus
0.05 e to the my
13i so I just played modulus over over
everything absolute value in order to
get rid of these small imaginary parts
to guarantee everything was was real but
shouldn't significantly affect the fact
anything and here it is in encodes we
have this return data frame drop bands
they're dropped all the Nance when
appending mature I think we had a one
row of NAND so just get rid of the Nan's
and then use the core function and
pandas for data frame and then compute
the eigenvalues here and the eigenvector
is using this linear algebra portion of
numpy la da di g and then finally i just
mapped the absolute value function over
the eigenvalues in order to make them
all all real valued
no we're working where right now
computing the correlation matrix
obviously even find it but then we're
going to filter that and remove the
noise out of it but there's not not just
one factor we're gonna keep all all 500
and so here's the here's the idea behind
behind the filter so we have we've have
a 500 by 500 matrix a 500 Gigan values
and so usually if you're if you're from
the PCA world then you have like high
dimensional data your first thought is
well let's let's do a pca decomposition
of data i want to figure out where do i
cut off
maybe only the first three eigenvalues
correspond to 99.9% of variance
explained and then the other 497 don't
don't matter in some financial context
it's it's very easy to know where to put
this cut off for instance if you look at
the variations of the yield curve or if
you look at the variations of a
commodity futures curve you can see it's
almost always three and usually usually
to get you like 99% of the way there but
it's clear you either put your threshold
after two or after three if you're
looking at equity portfolios in
particular long/short equity portfolios
and you do the same thing what's your
like 500 names it's it's not so clear
you tend to have these nice like sort of
decay functions for the for the
eigenvalues and do I put it after 10 do
I put it after 20 do I put it after 50
what what do I do
and so the motivation behind this the
construction of this correlation filter
is let's use this lambda plus value as
the threshold for it because that if the
matrix was purely random then land the
plus will be the largest that any noise
eigen about I can value can be for the
for the associated matrix and so we
decompose this list of eigen values
these 500 500 there's roughly 500 eigen
values into a lower portion lambda 1
through lambda K minus 1 and an upper
portion lambda K all the way up to
lambda n where we split it right at this
lambda plus eigen value which we compute
which is
so these two quantities again one number
of time series and the other the length
of the time series and after doing the
split everything that's below this land
the plus we're going to call noise we're
gonna take an average of all those noise
eigenvalues and we're going to replace
each of the noise eigenvalues with this
average why do that well it's a
correlation matrix correlation matrix
has a trace which is equal to the sum of
the diagonal which is going to be the
dimension of the of the matrix of 500 so
if I if I would ever change that
that trace I would no longer be a
correlation matrix this number of
variables so trace is something you want
to preserve for work relation matrix and
that completely fixes the the noise
portion here so all these noise portions
are lambda tilde and then lambda K
through lambda n these are kind of the
eigenvalues that have some information
content that are non non noise and
racist racist preserved and so here's
the filter just a few another few lines
of Pi Phi I love by felon by the way so
you can it's look a couple lines you can
do like in anything and I'm not a
computer scientist by training more of a
mathematician physicist that's love love
it and so here's the here's the filter
the first list comprehension this the
second one is just creating a new list
of noise eigenvalues and the third one
is constructing this list of new these
these new noise eigen values lambda
tilde is plus the information item
values and so now we have a new a new
matrix lambda lambda tilde and from that
we're going to use the original eigen
vectors to reconstruct this correlation
matrix this this equation right here -
Sigma Lambda tilde sigma inverse and so
it turns out when you do that you don't
get a bonafide correlation matrix so
you're pretty close but it's not quite
there the first thing I do is is
symmetrize a little numerical error that
comes in so it's not quite symmetric but
it's do it take it to take through the
symmetry nation row tilde plus row tilde
transpose and take half of that and then
the next issue is that there aren't
necessarily ones on the diagonal of this
new correlation matrix so it's a little
bit off the correlation matrix
fortunately there is open source code to
solve the optimization problem that
allows us to find the nearest
correlation matrix I put it in quotes
because we have to define say what we
mean by nearest and so in this setting
the nearest correlation matrix is the
one that solves this particular
optimization problem so want to minimize
over some space of matrices s X minus
this road tilde 1 the symmetrized
version of the reconstructed matrix but
s is going to be any invertible matrix
that is symmetric x equals x transpose
that has ones on the diagonal and is
positive definite all positive
eigenvalues and the norm here is the
so-called Frobenius norm which is just
the sum of the squares the differences
of the two two matrices were searching
over X and the matrix that we have
there's the definition of the norm so
it's nice that Mike
Croucher believes how you pronounce his
name has already implemented a function
that is amenable to solving this problem
and I'm just calling
it's called near near core it solves
exactly this problem and so here in this
RC mat we're just reconstructing this
row tilde and then symmetrize in the
next line and then find the nearest
correlation matrix there's it's a
iterative optimization procedure I just
set it to be so the max iterations to be
a thousand that converges fairly quickly
it only takes a couple I think it's in
milliseconds roughly two solves all this
problems rather rather quick and then
that's it now we have this in core new
filtered correlation matrix it is a
bonafide correlation matrix and we can
look at a few a bit of the some
information about this if you actually
compute its eigen values there they look
very different than those on a random
random matrix the largest eigenvalue is
on so 186 so it's a correlation matrix
for roughly 500 stocks so the sum of all
the eigenvalues is roughly roughly 500
and so the bulk of the weight is in this
first first eigenvalue and it is the
eigenvalue and the pca context that
corresponds to this market market factor
the more
the market is the largest component and
then you go down a little bit fourteen
nine six five and then roughly the firt
top ten i ghen values here are our
significant according to this random
matrix resolve but if you overlay this
distribution of eigenvalues this is all
the eigenvalues right here all the small
enough ones overlaid with the this
marchenko passed to our density the
lambda plus upper upper limit for this
filter is like roughly two point five so
everything lower than these top top ten
gets filtered away and replaced with its
with its average so even though there's
effectively there was like 500 to start
with we've broken it down to amount of
ten n dimensional dimensional problem
and just wanted to do a few plots here I
don't know there's too much information
in this plot but I think Seaborn's
heatmap plot is really cool should check
it out for the Seaborn's correlation
matrix he memorize Jenny matrix heat map
and here's a plot of the differences so
I have this filtered correlation matrix
and the original correlation matrix I
just took the differences of them and
plot the difference matrix in order to
see what are the values largely small
are they scattered is there any sort of
like pattern through them and there's a
few few specks where they're bigger than
like points 0.5 but most of all they're
sort of in the middle if you plot a
histogram over all of these differences
here's what it looks like the it's heavy
tailed itself you see like a few of
these larger ones at point 1 and minus
point 1 and then in the middle there was
highly concentrated around around 0 and
so for each of these correlation matrix
C's next thing we do is this reconstruct
the covariance matrices by multiplying
through by these square root of variance
terms that's what this block of code
does and we can start the covariance
matrices because when I get to this
asset allocation problem so there's
there are tons of problems that use the
require covariance matrices input and
Finance this is the one that I think is
probably the most widely used Markowitz
optimization or variance and Markowitz
optimization I didn't wanna stick with
vanilla optimization I want to add on an
extra term here so here's this is the
private problem we're trying to minimize
we have this quadrant
form WT Sigma hat w-where Sigma is the
covariance matrix and then minus these
lambda mu is the expected return vector
times W but then Plus this regularizer
term gamma with the l1 norm on on the
weights right here so sometimes this one
of the criticisms of this model is it
tends to focus a lot of the weight than
say just one or two a few of the stocks
and you can add on a penalty term in
order to get more diversification for
for that and we so we did that in the
next next line we're gonna be varying
lambda subject to the constraint all the
sum of all these W sub i's is one I
choose choose Mew to be 0.0003
because it's it's good don't like their
zero three to get good results but you
could as you incremented or as you
increase it or decrease that you you
just change the influence of this final
disperse off' ocation penalty so here's
the one of the things i just really
wanted to show you i'm CVX pi is is a
very nice interface on top of CB x opt I
think eCos SCS and there's a several
other optimizers and the the way you set
up one of these problems is in the
swallowing for loop you say what you
want to optimize over the variable you
set up the objective function want to
minimize a certain quadratic form this X
the covariance matrix times second terms
this expected return term and the last
ones the middle is a ssin term see what
your constraints are and they do problem
set up the problem and then you do solve
and then that's it
and what the CVX pine does for you first
of all it checks whether or not you have
a well-defined optimization convex
optimization problem if you don't it
will say no go find another optimizer
for whatever your your solvent gun if it
does then it will branch it will it will
symbolically trying to figure out what
type of problem you have and then send
it to the right algorithm find the
results return back the weights and
return back a bunch of other information
associated with the authorization check
it out very easy to use very well done
it's built on top of a lot of optimizers
have been around for a while so i'm
pretty
pretty confident and and using it it
also saves the pain from having to like
contort your problem into somebody's
very specific form for their optimizer
where you have a lot of air dudes math
math Mitchell math algebra hairs then
I'll just show the final so here we run
this optimization problem for varying
lambdas on on both the unfiltered and
non unfiltered correlation matrix and
then next part we plot the efficient
frontier for both and this the main
takeaway is that they're both of them
are in green and blue but they're almost
exactly the same so even though we just
we removed 490 of these eigenvalues out
of them roughly the 500 and then replace
them with the average we get roughly the
same same results which is a good thing
because everything's now being done what
they pay more a nicer correlation matrix
so I don't have these like tiny tiny
eigenvalues they're like 10 e to the
minus 15 which usually result in lots of
numerical issues through the other parts
of the process and I think that's that's
all here's a here's my email and a few
few references they're talks on github
and it should be in the URL thank you
mmm
I think if there's I think that the
normal overall it'll be smaller if
they're more equally distributed then if
if they're if there's only one or two
that gets the bulk of that concentration
I believe so
mmm you could do it I'm kind of hesitant
to reconstruct a covariance matrix from
something that's not a correlation
matrix so I like when you do this
process you sort of gets like slightly
out of the space a correlation matrix
sees but just barely
and you're just perturbing it like right
right back in to find the nearest one
you could do it there's an imprint I
mean there's nothing that's wrong that's
identically an issue here but it's I'd
rather work with a bona fide correlation
matrix the one that's not not quite one
I haven't tried it myself I like it
though cuz it's like a very Bayesian
idea where you sort of like taking this
combination but Rincon's estimators are
taking a combination of the actual data
that's what you sort of expect than that
but it's a good good idea very true and
I've had several my college so I haven't
looked into it but ones that are more
experts on this and as well as like more
Bayesian statistics tell me that they've
worked with shrinkage estimators and
they don't they always have some
problems with what they're doing I don't
I can't speak to it to myself though I
haven't worked with it but I there seems
like a good idea I haven't looked at it
the only thing for lambda plus that we
care about is the number of points in
the time series of the number of time
series I'm sorry that's that's very true
so you can use these sort of like
weighted average covariance estimate
estimators but then you're you have an
effective in like even if I'm using a
weighted average like a expansion moving
average estimator for the commence
matrix then if it's 100 points but with
this the effective number of points is
like 20 or 30 so that's that's something
that you could you could probably adapt
this to plug in for n but it would
another interesting point is that it
kind of tells you like how many how many
points in the time series you need in
order to get good estimates on these
matrices a lot of times in finance we're
going to be using like 200 data points
to estimate a 500 by 500 matrix and from
a lot of little it's a physical point of
view that's bad because you just have so
much noise and the estimator itself it's
not going to work if you try to apply
one of these filters in that case you're
basically just gonna filter out
everything and you're not gonna be left
with anything in the problem so it's
thank you